we begin with this Republicans are
claiming victory in a closely watched
congressional race in Ohio that is
officially as you've heard too close to
call
Republican tribe Alderson leads Democrat
Danny O'Connor by more than 1,700 votes
in the special election for a seat that
the GOP is controlled for more than
three decades election officials say
more than 8,000 absentee and provisional
ballots must be counted before they can
declare a winner ed O'Keefe is in
Columbus Ohio with what the close vote
could mean for the November midterm
elections ed good morning good morning
bianna The Columbus Dispatch calls this
race a nail-biter and it sure is but
those provisional ballots can't be
counted for another 10 days even if they
lose Democrats say that the close margin
suggests big trouble for the GOP here in
Ohio and across the country this fall
can you believe how close this is
declining to concede Democrat Danny
O'Connor says he's waiting until all
votes are counted we need to make sure
that this process is respected because
too many people have worked too hard too
many people want to have a real voice in
Washington but Republican candidate Troy
ballers in declared victory leading by
less than one point I'm going to promise
to you that I'm going to work
relentlessly relentlessly for this 12th
congressional district Republicans have
controlled this suburban congressional
district for more than 30 years and
usually win by double digits but in the
final weeks of the race O'Connor closed
the gap by calling for new leadership in
Washington Ohio Democratic Chairman
David if we can learn the lessons from
this talk to talk to swing voters I
actually think we have a chance to do
great things all over the state Troy
Bolger sin' he is the guy another factor
in Ohio President Trump who won the
district by 11 points in 2016 and
campaigned for bald erson over the
weekend we have a man that's going to
fight for you he's gonna fight for Ohio
mr. Trump Twitter late Tuesday that
because he showed up in Ohio there was a
big turn for the better
now Troy wins a great victory I'd like
to thank President Trump
but some Democrats said the president's
visit here drove them to the polls I get
a sense him coming probably made you
even more determined to vote absolutely
I was gonna vote anyway but that
definitely pulled me out
Democrats and Republicans spent more
than eight million dollars on this
special election a big sum for a race in
the middle of the summer and here's the
thing no matter who wins this first
round there's going to be a rematch
because troy ball derson and danny
o'connor they're their party's nominees
for the general election in November
flat as always all eyes on Ohio Edie
thanks very much